Israeli security forces have killed two
Palestinians during a raid in the
occupied West Bank they were shot in the
Janine refugee camp in the North Ibrahim
is on the line from Ramallah in the
occupied West Banks only that what's the
situation there is this raid still
ongoing as we speak
Spanish the Israeli forces have
withdrawn from the camp after armed
clashes continued as far as residents
tell us in the camps for three hours the
race began with the Special Forces
leading into the genuine refugee camp
using Palestinian license polluted cars
and then they were caught or figured out
by the armed men in the camp and they
clashed with them leading the Israeli
forces to send more than 70 vehicles of
reinforcements from the Israeli military
now according to the Israeli forces the
raid was the goals of the raid was to
arrest one Palestinian but eventually as
we know the situation engineering has
been a very tense since last year where
armed men in the campus really confront
the Israeli forces with armed with arms
now two Palestinians which killed
including adham Japan according to
people in the campus a member of the
gene Battalion and he was killed while
he was after he was shot in the
afternoon now the second Palestinian
he's a teacher in his late 50s and
according to people there he was trying
to Aid at hand after he was shot near
his house so this raises the total
number of people who were killed in
Janine just since the beginning of this
year and we're only in the 19th of
January to 17 people but nine of them
were killed in Janine that gives you an
idea about the 10th situation in the
refugee camp there were Palestinians
tell us that it will only understands
the language of forces and why they take
up arms and they fight as well repulsive
but haven't been reading the refugee
camp and its surrounding for almost a
daily basis now